here's an interesting question for you
what does it mean to be
an adult well stanford university's
former dean of freshmen
looks for the answers in her new book
your turn
how to be an adult julie lithgot haims
also offers advice for living what she
calls a more authentic
adulthood before we talk with her we
decided to ask some 20-somethings
what they think it means to be an adult
there's a stereotype around what adults
do you have a job
you have a family you have a house and
kids but i'm 21 and i have none of those
things
i'm a grown up and i take care of myself
as much as i can and to me that's being
an adult
i would say once i moved out on my own
with my twin brother
taking those steps were just making sure
i maintained my bill stayed on top of my
bills and just making sure that
i never had the reliance on my parents
anymore i think
i'm defining success these days as
being happy or at least being content
with myself and with my surroundings and
having the freedom
to make the choices that i've decided i
need to make for myself
whatever that means the steps that i
took to get to where i am now
i don't know if i should call them steps
felt like a slip and slide at one point
i felt like i was tumbling down the
stairs
it feels like if i don't get that great
job out of graduation
if i can't support myself if i can't
live on my own if i can't like do all
these things that adults are supposed to
do with my
failure i think i have
tangled with the idea of what it means
to be an adult and what it means to be
independent or what it means to be
successful and i'm realizing that
that is not a really clear line there
are really no check boxes
it's just really understanding what is
required of you to succeed in life or to
just survive
and choosing to do it
and julie left hams who is also a cbs
news contributor joins us now julie good
morning
i'm 64 and i'm still trying to answer
this question what it means to be an
adult
we heard we heard all of those young
folks talking about what they think it
means how do you define it
first of all those young people headed
absolutely right thank you for opening
the segment with their voices because it
really is all about them
you know the old definitions of adulting
from the 18th and 19th and 20th century
were
finish school get a job leave home marry
and have kids and those definitions
don't fit our new reality
those definitions were gendered they
assumed everyone was hetero
today we have more choice and more
freedom for example millennials and
older gen z's they're going to live to a
hundred
so why stop your education at 22 if
you're going to live that long
what hasn't changed is that humans still
need to fend for themselves pay
their bills but maybe you need to live
at home today because the cost of living
in your hometown
is so expensive you have high student
loans that have uh
outpaced salaries and wages maybe you're
gonna go live with a set of friends your
chosen fam
where you're gonna share and barter and
co-create the community that feels right
for you
so it doesn't really matter who you live
with it matters how you live
are you showing up in that environment
as an adult are you taking care of your
bills are you taking care of your mental
health are you taking care of the people
around you you say it's not a checklist
it's a process
what exactly do you mean
well the five definitions of adulthood
were very much a checklist from the past
today we know
it's a process it's not about a lockstep
plan or some kind of
perfect set of steps you have to adhere
to
it's about a mindset that says hey i'm
going to try to figure stuff out
i want to be independent i want to be
self-reliant but i'm learning
we have to reframe our mindset carol
dweck at stanford
her research is on growth mindset let's
get out of the fixed mindset that says
i'm perfect and reframe it to i'm trying
to get better at this or
reframe this is hard to i do hard things
when we can be humble and appreciate
that if we can bring a beginner's
mindset
to the process of adulting then we can
lean into what i call
life's beautiful f words failing
floundering fumbling falling okay these
are
life's greatest teachers if we can
accept that
feedback is probably the most important
one
if we can be humble in the face of these
things we can learn and grow
and that's the path to a meaningful
rewarding adulthood
yeah you called feedback in your book
the ultimate growth hormone
you said you said we should change i
suck to i haven't learned to do this yet
change this is hard to i do hard things
but your book was interesting to me
julie because you made a point of
talking to all different kinds of
adults all different you you really seem
to be going for
inclusivity and diversity in this
particular book in a way that i hadn't
seen before
absolutely gail as a black and biracial
and queer person i am really aware
that all lives should matter so
we as writers have to do the work to
ensure that all the lives do matter on
the page so what i've done in this book
is make sure my narrative
is very inclusive of humans of all
backgrounds racially ethnically in terms
of gender sexual orientation
in terms of mental health status in
terms of their degree of education
i've brought close to three dozen other
humans into these pages
to tell the story of what adulting looks
like
you know i think in sharing the stories
of so many people folks are going to
learn like wow there are folks
from completely different walks of life
who are nevertheless
the same as me as maya angelou said
right we are more like my friends than
we are
unalike and that's one of the things i'm
trying to demonstrate
in these pages about adulting hey julie
your your last book was called how to
raise an adult it was for parents so i'm
curious
would you advise parents listening to
buy this book
for their adults to be and if so what do
you hope those adults to be get out of
it
well here's what i'm hearing some of my
early readers have in fact been parent
teen combos or parent 20 something
combos
and the younger person the 18 20 22 year
old is apparently saying
oh hey mom dad parent i want to talk to
you about what's on page so and so okay
it's
it's appearing to be kind of an
opportunity to push the door
open for clearer communication more
authentic
honest communication um that the young
adult wants to have with their parent
which i think is fantastic so for
parents
read this and be humble and take an
interest in what your young adult
children might want to be telling you
okay yeah
i'm humbled every day julie
adulthood yes julie left god thank you
so much
the book is your turn how to be an adult
it is on sale today